[Music]
[Applause]
Herm Edwards he knows the business ESPN
NFL college football analyst uh what do
you make of what Dion's saying that uh
other schools are saying hey don't go
there because he's going to go elsewhere
yeah I dealt with that myself when I got
back he's going to go back to pro
football all those things um that's just
part of it but it's kind of ironic
anymore because as much as the players
say well the coach is going to leave by
the way they leave too
now the portal the transfer portal yeah
you gotta recruit them after every game
if they're not playing right so it works
both ways what is tougher coaching in
the NFL or coaching in college now oh I
would say college really because of the
fact that um you got to constantly
recruit your guys um and you know and
that's just part of the deal now that
that's part part of what you do um and
uh it's difficult at times because
you're trying to build a football team
and when the season ends you don't know
who's leaving who's staying um you know
a freshman guy has been pretty good
played a little bit all of a sudden some
other schools after him he comes in and
he tells you his story and and certain
guys obviously are saying he's schools
are after me coach and here's the number
and so can you match the number right
it's interesting what's the biggest
number you had to pay out H well I'm not
gonna get into that I'll tell you this I
lost eight of them you lost eight
players one of them happen one of them
might win Heisman oh okay J Daniels yeah
right I had Jaden for three years I had
him as a freshman that's a special
player yeah he's really good good kid I
talked to him probably once every other
week so LSU came up with a better offer
well I just I don't know what you know
it just like I said I lost it's legal
it's it's legal though is right yeah
yeah good for them he's playing
good oh I love it
nil transfer portal um it's free agency
I know I know and I can't imagine like
you're watching your kids and then
you're like hey is anybody seen Tommy uh
you didn't hear uh I think he's visiting
uh whatever Texas A&M wait a minute I
thought he isn't he happy here he wants
to be
happier you know what's really
interesting now because I'm getting
calls from scouts that are looking at
some of the guys that left and they're
calling me and say coach I know he was
with you for two or three years can you
tell me a little bit about him I said oh
yeah he's great kid whatever you know
I'm giving him a good recommendation
because they were all good kids it's
just in in in today's world um it's just
part of it you know it when when you get
into this especially in college coaching
anymore all right let's look at the uh
Harbaugh Michigan situation what do you
think of the crime uh what do you think
of the punishment well I'll say this um
I think it's galvanizing this football
team I think he's done a a fabulous job
of of of dealing uh with with with the
with a team that has a lot of mental
toughness um and I just think that it's
unfortunate uh the situation that has
occurred uh
this uh you know looking at at at
signals and trying to get signals this
has been going on but could you imagine
one of your assistant coaches doing that
and you and you not knowing it
well you know hey all I know is this and
you know this too Dan
um when you are the
leader no matter what you get to make a
lot of
decisions right and you get to make
decisions
you set
policies but here's the deal it's
like when you watch a football game a
coach makes a lot of decisions on what's
about to be
called but he has no control of what
those players are about to do when the
ball's being hyped and it's the same way
in college football pro football you
make a lot of decisions you tell people
you trust them and
you let them go do their job
and then when things like this
occur guess what it's on you it's on you
yeah and and that's part of it it's hard
and I'm not going to get into the weeds
with it because I don't know the whole
story
um you know it's just it's it's a hard
deal man and I've sat in that seat and I
know I know how that feels talking to
Herm Edwards former NFL player uh coach
now working for the Mother Ship I saw
this uh in inside USC with Scott wolf a
great uh reporter Lincoln Riley's name
just keeps coming up for jobs several
college coaches told me yesterday they
heard that Riley has interest in the
Texas A&M job he's revered in Texas the
coach said he likes recruiting in Texas
has High School connections there I
think there's something to it what do
you make of that well that you know he's
a he's a hot commodity I mean if you
want offense if you want to score 50
points he's your guy there's no doubt
about that um and this is part of
college football anymore you know these
guys move around college coaches move
around more than NFL coaches be quite
honest yeah you you can't keep your
coaching sta they're always it seems
like you're losing a guy or two every
year um and I just think if you
know if they come after you and and your
contract states that you you know that
you can leave a lot of these guys will
leave I think a lot of these contracts
now that these coaches have um there's
certain stipulations in the contract
where you got to stay a certain amount
of time so but you you said I I think
you're on record is saying Lane kein
would be a good choice for Texas S&M
sure I've known Lane I mean Lane was a
ball boy when we were in Tampa together
with Monty Monty was a coordinator down
I was down there with Tony you know and
and so I've known Lane quite a long time
I think he brings he he brings offense
and and in college football now I mean
you've watch it Dan I mean you you gotta
score you can't even stay in the game if
you don't score over 30 points uh you
know you got to score the ball in
college football because the way they
play anymore they spread you out and
they use the whole field they just throw
it around a lot they just do that that's
what it looks like and he can recruit um
he'll be good with the alums um he's
always gonna have an opinion which is
kind of good right he can Stir It Up
with the best of them true I just think
you know he would be a guy he's used to
the conference he he he can recruit in
the conference conference he's good in
the living room uh and he's a good
football
coach yeah you know you're talking about
coaches you're on the move and uh you
know we don't even blink when you know
somebody you when you say why you could
end up at Tex A&M or Lincoln Riley could
end up at it didn't used to be that way
no no like there's no loyalty at
anywhere it feels like in college
football like the players the coaches
whatever is best for me it's all
individualistic and and and that's the
hardest that's the hard part especially
if you come from the old school right
because you can't stay too old school
you kind of move on but I just think
that there's certain guys you've watched
uh at at certain universities and
they've been there for quite a quite
sometime you know they're not leaving
they're just kind of hunkered in there
and there's other guys that move and I
just think according to what generation
you're in you know that's the mindset
you have as a coach could you see an
offense Herm going old school like
Nebraska used to when they with that
running attack
that I mean big linemen like you know
because it feels like somebody's going
to be have a Counterattack where
everybody's got smaller quicker
defensive players where I maybe we just
go we have a home field advantage this
is our system we're going to do it can
you see that happening great point I I
don't think you go to the extent of army
but I think you make a great Point uh
and and there's some schools you know
you look at
Washington uh you look at Oregon they
still run the ball right they they can
pound it on you Oregon state does a
really good job it's a pro offense coach
does a marvelous job he uses the tight
ends he uses play action passes they can
pound you right Stanford was like that
when coach Shaw was there you know I
mean we were like that a little bit at
Arizona State we won to run the ball we
had some good running backs Rashad white
obviously with the bucks now you know we
had auk as one of the receiver we had
some guys we were a pro style offer we
weren't opened up as
much so there's some coaches that still
do that the problem with that is
this when you get behind in college
football you get down three scores you
have to have the ability to open it up
you just do yeah right
yeah it's part of the deal great to talk
to you as always hope you're having fun
oh I'm having a lot of fun I'm I'm like
you every time something
I don't even scratch my head anymore I
go oh okay what
else it's always something dead right
you think you seen it all you look again
you go really
okay he's Herm Edwards ESPN NFL college
football analyst former uh NFL and
college coach thank you her thank you my
friend